foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm James page at the ftth council
Europe meeting in Madrid and I'm with
Thomas lemonskas who is the Deputy
Secretary General of the international
telecommunications Union the itu Thomas
thank you for coming and talking to us
you've been speaking at the event here
in Madrid today and you're outlining
some of the initiatives that the itu set
in train to help with the deployment
across Europe of full fiber everywhere
that that everybody's so Keen to see
could you tell us a bit more about them
definitely so maybe just starting with
eight years and you know and of course
we're working within Europe but also
Beyond Europe and as a global
organization and we have this different
aspects organization that helps us do
those initiatives so first of all we are
UN agency and that means every country
of the world is Our member but we also
have sector members private sector
members more than 900 of them that work
with those member states on the other
hand also standardization organization
so we we issue standards and we work
with our focal points which are a lot of
times ministries of telecommunications
or digital Ministries telecommunications
Regulators so through that angles there
are certain things we do where we can do
you know so first of all standards so
most of uh most of the fiber to the home
connections are based on IQ standards
and pawn or passive Optical Network
standards that has now the whole roadmap
you know it's I think we're now in the
seventh generation of them and we're now
reaching in terms of standardization of
Technology 50 gigabits per second per
wavelengths I know the deployment is
still you know needs to catch up with
that but that's that's how it always is
we then of course help shape investment
environment and regulate your thinking
around that through sharing information
best practices you know infrastructure
information for example we have
Broadband maps that are publicly
available we're now developing ways to
share open data on fiber networks as
well with other organizations we also
have things like Last Mile toolkit
connectivity toolkit like infrastructure
business case toolkit to help regulate
us and investors in differentiations
assess what's needed to invest in fiber
and as well as other Technologies
and lastly but but definitely not not
least is is building Partnerships you
know and definitely the small District
holder public private Partnerships to
progress what we call digital
development for all so from a very
rather specific ones like a giga
initiative to bring connectivity to
every school and every student where we
mapped more than 2 million schools you
know we connected there are more than 2
million students in in the more than
five and a half thousand schools and
this is our joint Initiative for Unicef
to broader initiative like partner to
connect where where different
stakeholders pledged more than 60
billion uh sorry more than 30 billion in
pledges through the 600 pledges so
really trying to Galvanize everyone for
that joint action okay that's great
thank you for for explaining it and I
think conversations have uh have moved
in in recent years within this sector
there were seemingly obsessed to think
about the the deployment and and getting
fiber rolled out but nowadays it's just
we're also talking about making sure
people are on networks and you talk
about connectivity in general whether
whichever the technology is so so
getting getting the connectivity right
is just as important as the deployment
to you no indeed and that's across the
Technologies we see the same from the
mobile sector you know when they also
talk about how many people are connected
you know versus and and that and that
only marginal piece is not connected
versus how many are using and the same
with the fiber and I think definitely
infrastructure is important piece of the
puzzle and we need to make sure that
that's there but also use of it is
important however the big important
argument or issue there is affordability
aspects as well and that's kind of
connects between the infrastructure and
use because the cheap ways to deploy
know the more competitive the market is
and the more you can have that better
prices to the users is clearly one of
the key factors that will drive the use
on the other side and that's we see
there's a big affordability as such both
of connectivity then going devices we
see the core issue across the different
uh different technology users and then
of course other issues which also
important such as digital literacy you
know having that real user need for that
technology and and you know and is also
super important so I think this is a
gamut of aspects we also need to work to
and it's important for the private
sector players to look and so also for a
government not just to look at
infrastructure piece but to look about
digital education of their populations
and also affordability you know and kind
of incomes as well okay so um the the EC
has its path to a digital decade plan
um because she's sort of focusing on
that deployment do you think that's a
realistic plan are we on the right path
will we be delivering against it I mean
I wouldn't want to kind of uh comment
directly on EC plan I think it's good to
have an ambition and I think it's good
to push for ambition and we see the
results and including today we saw
especially on the deployment part you
know we saw results we see new proposals
from European uh commission coming of
the new religious initiatives and again
they understand Market players are
discussing in different aspects of them
but again intention is clear to really
push it and I think that ambition is
really showing results you know from our
side we have this different Ambitions on
a global level for example our what we
call connect 2030 agenda and that is you
know that is a global agenda but in a
similar vein you know trying to really
you know make sure that as many people
are connected but they are connected in
an inclusive way you can access the
reason meaningful way and also taking
care of these side effects you know like
for example resilience making sure and
we heard that word as well make sure
that resilience is really taking account
from physical to cyber cyber resilience
make sure that we take care of inclusion
so that everyone you know is not
including rural areas and and different
uh less included groups are connected
and also contributing our positive bit
to the country to the challenge of the
such as climate crisis and again it was
really encouraging to hear that the fdth
council also have now sustainability
group to to look at that so I think
that's kind of corresponds both on the
global and European level and I think
ambition then allows to drive the
development as well
fantastic well I think everybody here
shares the same ambition it's uh great
to hear about the initiatives from the
itu that are going to help push us along
towards that Thomas thank you very much
for for coming and taking a little bit
of time to to talk to us this afternoon
thank you very much James really
appreciate it thank you
[Music]
[Applause]